so this is part of the fill-in-the-blank
game that we're gonna play Aryan
squashing any Antonio Brown to Tampa Bay
possibility is blank absolute fact and
Mike there's one thing you forgot when
you when you were talking about this
just think let's just say that Bruce
Arians had a soft spot in his heart for
a Antonio Brown and let's just say they
signed him as Brandon Tierney said to a
veteran minimum contract and let's just
say the first game of the season that
Chris Godwin is seven for a hundred and
sixteen and Mike Evans is five for a
hundred and five with two touchdowns and
and an internal bra has two targets one
catch for 19 yards what do you think
Antonio Browns reaction is going to be
when he's two targets one catch for 19
yards is he gonna say hey I'm just here
for the team and you know so that is the
biggest thing that I thought of about
this whole thing Mike and that is that
it would be hard very hard for Antonio
Brown to come in as a third wheel in
that receiving court let me take it
another direction my answer to this
question is Aryans squashing any a/b to
Tampa Bay possibility is irrelevant
because he's got three active
investigations that the NFL is still
potentially going to suspend him for
this sexual assault rape lawsuit from
last September the the alleged
harassment of the person who took spoke
to Robert Clem Co of si.com last year
with another incident about Antonio
Brown and he allegedly went after her on
text message and then the incident from
earlier this year with the driver of the
moving truck that he didn't want to pay
so he threw a rock at the truck and then
allegedly beat up the driver and busted
open the back of the truck and took his
stuff out he may not play at all this
year I mean the easy if Tom Brady needed
to be placated the easiest way to do it
Peter would have been to say sure we'll
sign Antonio Brown knowing full well
that he's probably not going to play at
all this year yeah this is this in many
ways Mike it's a non-starter and I think
you're
right that he's gonna have some sort of
suspension in 2020 if he got signed or
if somebody wanted to sign him we just
don't know how long that's going to be
all right next topic the first person
Tom Brady called once he got all those
cell phone numbers from the Buccaneers
was probably who Mike Evans and he said
you were going to be a very very happy
man because I'm gonna throw you nine
hundred footballs I think Mike Evans I'm
not saying he's going to be Randy Moss
because he's not Randy Moss but I'm
saying that the last time that Tom Brady
had a big strong speedy wide receiver in
the Mike Evans realm Mike Evans range
really is Randy Moss productive strong
and big so Tom Brady can throw the ball
up for Mike Evans and he's gonna catch a
lot of them now I will say this Mike
Evans and Jameis Winston made some
beautiful music together too
so I'm not saying the numbers I'm
exaggerating obviously but I'm not
saying the numbers are gonna be all that
much different but I think he is going
to get very very he's gonna get the ball
an awful lot the first one though I do
know who the first person he called
and that was Byron Leftwich because he
wanted to start the process he FaceTime
with Byron Leftwich for 90 minutes on
Wednesday night after he got the deal
done at least verbally or however that
whole thing worked with Ariens and and
Jason light that first night see I think
the first player that he should have
called is oj Howard he's become kind of
the forgotten man he's never lived up to
his potential and to the extent that tom
brady is looking for another Gronk
that's the guy that I want to get to
quickly and say forget about the first
three years I know how to get the ball
to a tight end and I know what I need
out of my tight end to make a difference
to open up the rest of the offense and
we are gonna work together any way we
can to allow you to reach your full
potential and I'm here to help you
become the
that you always were supposed to be so
Mike Evans
he's gonna be Mike Evans you don't you
don't need to give Mike Evans a pep talk
oh J Howard's the one who's been the
disappointment he's the one who was the
subject of trade rumors he's the one
that he needs to get through to alright
well good well end that topic I'll take
the compliment and move on if you were a
general manager interested in signing
Cam Newton your first question to him
would be what if we bring you in you
don't win the starting job are you gonna
be a team guy and support the starting
quarterback and Mike I refer mostly to
the Jacksonville Jaguars because if I'm
the Jaguars and I'm Dave Caldwell and
I'm Doug Marrone I'm rubbing my hands
together and I'm saying I'm going to get
either the first pick in the draft
in 2011 who's got a bur up his saddle
with something to prove or I'm gonna get
the first pick in the draft in 2015
who's got a bur up his saddle and he's
got something to prove I have a gift for
not much money okay I'm gonna get one of
those too and that's gonna be my
question for each guy but particularly
for Cam Newton because look Jameis
Winston hasn't been an MVP and Jameis
Winston is coming off a slap in the face
30 interception season Cam Newton's just
coming off being hurt and so I would
want to know if Gardner Minshew is the
starting quarterback of this team as
silly as it sounds but if he is are you
gonna support him and are you gonna be a
good number two for as long as you are
number two see my question is much more
general much more open-ended and I think
the answer will be much more telling
about the current mindset of Cam Newton
my question will be how much money do
you want and how he answers that
question is gonna tell me exactly where
his mindset is does he view himself as
an unquestioned starter who would not
accept anything other than the number
one spot on the depth chart does he say
I'll take whatever you pay me I just
want to be on a team does he say I want
thirty million a year you know he had
that comment
Matt rule was making the rounds four
weeks ago at the Scouting Combine with
that bullcrap notion that he's looking
forward to coaching Cam Newton which was
all about trying to conjure up a trade
market when there was none and Cam
Newton had the social media video where
he says all I want is a commitment what
kind of a commitment do you want
financially because that's gonna tell me
whether or not he fits with what I'm
looking for am I looking for a clear-cut
number one starter like the Chargers
should be with Cam Newton am I looking
for a guy who maybe fits in as a backup
who can help room gardner minshew and
play if minsu stumbles what Cam Newton
wants financially is gonna answer all
those questions Peter yeah but still I
mean look especially with a team with a
lot of cap room you could make Cam
Newton happy I mean you're not we're not
paying you twenty five million dollars
you could you could structure a contract
that is a ridiculously incentive Laden
contract so that he'd make really good
money if he played but I mean to me if
I'm Cam Newton I'm gonna say hey I'll
work with you and I'm not gonna be
greedy or whatever it is because I want
to get to second base
if I if i I know that that's a trap
question okay how much money do you want
why in the world would you say thirty
million then they're gonna say hey have
a good life I mean you're gonna say hey
I'll work with you let's we'll just
figure out what's fair and I'll work
with you to me well weakest thing is are
you gonna be go ahead
nope it the Colts just gave Phillip
Rivers twenty five million dollars after
he turned into an interception machine
last year with that funky sidearm motion
in his he's not taking a cam he's not
kidding I've taken if Cam Newton's have
but but he gave him twenty five million
dollars Cam Newton is worth it cam doing
one year's out of one year Wow anyone
hotter he's not hurt yeah I here's the
thing before I do the dance with Cam
Newton obviously I'm not gonna sign him
until I can give him a proper physical
but I think I I don't think Cam Newton's
gonna mince words about what he wants
financially I think he will be very
candid about it and be very open about
it I just think that's gonna tell you
where his head will Lisa
one of how he fits I think you I think
at least 25 million at least
if rivers and breeze I tell you I tell
you I iced I tell him forget it I'm not
paying you 25 million how do I know who
you are
and if I pay you 25 million that means
you're a guaranteed day one starter and
and look I'm not saying that he isn't a
starting quarterback in any way shape or
form he is but I don't know what he is
right now he hasn't played football
effectively for a year and a half he's
coming off shoulder surgery and foot
surgery I don't know what this guy is
and so that that's why to guarantee him
a lot of money I think is foolish well
but that's why you want to do a proper
physical before you sign the document
but knowing where his head's at
and look I he posted workout video
yesterday the guy looks bigger than ever
the guy looks fine to me now that's far
different than playing on a football
field but I would I would want to know
right out of the gates what he what I'm
getting myself into financially before I
continue to dance alright one more
before we have to take a break as two
new teammates based upon free agency
movement you are most excited to see who
and who I'm most excited to see Tom
Brady and Tom Brady you know and when I
saw this question early this morning I
said to myself well I could think of a
lot of guys who you know a lot of teams
who have signed a bunch of guys you know
if I'm Sam Darnell I'm happy that they
rebuilt the offensive line and and if
I'm the Giants I'm happy I have bradbury
and and you know the Ravens with you
know with their pickups you know I love
coleus Campbell but the biggest thing is
Mike you know Tom Brady just conquers
all and he'd be my 1 and 2 for the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers
see I'm looking at Josh Allen and Stefon
Diggs because Josh Allen's got that
rocket arm and he hasn't had a receiver
like Stefon Diggs yet in his two prior
years in the NFL and and Diggs can run
every route and he can run the deep
route and Josh Allen can throw it out of
the stadium literally and I can't wait
to see what those two do in Buffalo
conjuring memories of the ok gun offense
but
potentially as they start to put some
real weapons in place do you think that
Diggs is gonna make a difference for
Buffalo as they try to maybe fill that
void at the top of the AFC East and
there's no question about it Mike he he
obviously gives them something they
haven't had which is a sure-handed deep
threat so that's that's very good now
you know I have some issues with how
much they paid for them and because they
certainly paid an awful lot for them and
there's no doubt in my mind that coming
soon whenever it is I don't know what
year it'll be but coming soon is gonna
be you know a pretty expensive contract
so you know look one of the things that
always happens when you trade for
somebody you have to understand that if
you trade a one you know the Colts did
this obviously the bills did this what
you're also doing is not only are you
signing to Forrest Buckner for 21
million a year you are foregoing
the cheap contract that you could have
signed the 13th pick in the draft - and
the same thing with you know a receiver
like Stefon Diggs because look at it
this is the richest year for receivers
maybe ever in NFL draft history there's
been 85 drafts this is the 85th draft
and this is probably the richest year
for receivers ever and last year Mike
you know DK Metcalf 64 Terry McLaren 76
and again I'm not saying that Stefon
Diggs isn't worth it but he is gonna
have to be a truly great player a great
player an all-pro player to justify what
they paid for him and not only in draft
choice compensation but in forgoing a
manageable player maybe a guy like CD
Lamar you know or somebody like that who
they could have picked in his stead and
it wasn't just a first-round pick that
the Cowboys gave up to get Amari Cooper
a year and a half ago it was a 1 a 5 a 6
this year and a 4 next year so it's that
first round or you could get on a cheap
contract and three other guys that you
can roll the dice in maybe get somebody
who can be a contributing
for your team over the long haul we got
to take a break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports